nearly every year in the united states
millions of periodical cicadas emerge
from over a decade of underground
transformation
in 2021 brew 10 takes its turn
route 10 is one of the largest groups of
cicadas that emerge every 17 years
their powerful chirps can be heard in 15
states
periodical cicadas are grouped by broods
defined by the year and how often they
emerge
insects in 12 broods emerge once every
17 years
while three groups mostly in the
southeastern united states
come out every 13 years within these
broods there are three types of cicadas
decem decula
and casino for decades
researchers have been fascinated by how
these life cycles form and how they
might change in the future
in 1988 researcher chris simon published
the first
evidence of 17-year cicadas switching to
a 13-year life cycle
we were just sampling the entire range
of
the largest brood of 13 year cicadas and
as we got into the northern part of that
distribution
we noticed that they were slightly
smaller that their abdomens were more
black instead of orange
we didn't think too much about it until
we got back to the laboratory
and we looked at their dna and we
realized that the dna
of the northern ones that were smaller
and blacker
it actually matched the mitochondrial
dna
of the 17 years catas rather than the 13
year cicadas
so then it immediately came to me that
they had to be 17 years kate cades that
recently
switched their life cycle to 13 years
recently
in geological time that is the shift
likely happened about 200 000 years ago
the boundary between these different
species of 13-year cicadas
occur at the border between northeast
and southeast deciduous forests
[Music]
simon believes that a warmer climate in
the northern mississippi river valley
caused this life cycle shift over this
warming period cicadas would come out
more often four years early but it
happened so many times and so often
that gradually became genetically
assimilated so
rather than being a plastic trade is now
a genetic trait
these findings suggest that life cycles
are a plastic trait
that cicadas can alter in response to
changing environments
all periodical skaters we think have the
opportunity
to come out four years early or four
years late they're growing at all
different rates underground
in order to become synchronized and
periodical
they had to develop a waiting period so
by
waiting in these four-year windows
they'll have more individuals to come
out with them
it allows evolutionary flexibility to an
organism that
otherwise has this very rigid programmed
life cycle
emerging in greater numbers at the same
time
gives the insects a better chance of
surviving
and reproducing simon had repeatedly
seen reports about cicadas
emerging early in 2017 she surveyed the
four-year early emergence of brood 10
cicadas
in the washington dc area we've never
seen such
massive early emergences with singing
for the entire four weeks
we drive around and we listen for
the sounds of the different species and
then we record them here on our
automatic
data logger this year we've come back
just to make sure that the main range of
the brood
is also appearing in exactly the same
places and they are
so everywhere that we saw four year
early 2017 we're now seeing
even more dense populations of brood
tent
it is possible that enough cicadas
survived and reproduced in 2017
that they will come out in 2034
although another four-year early
emergence of brood 10
could happen at the same time
researchers are still
uncertain how cicadas keep track of when
these four-year windows are coming up
simon plans to study whether cicada's
epigenetics
changes to gene expression could be
driving this capability
if we have continued climate change
which we're expecting and a continued
warming then we would expect more and
more
individuals to come out four years early
if simon's hunch is right
we may not have to wait another 17 years
to meet brood 10 once again
you